[Música]
hace siete años france24 comenzó a
contar las historias de las mujeres y
tres años atrás el nació de ellas hoy
para hablar con enfoque de género en
español mi nombre es ángela gómez y
bienvenidos a nuestra edición especial
de aniversario en cuatro idiomas conmigo
estarán hoy desde parís las
presentadoras del programa en francés
actuales en inglés definitivo en
presente y en árabe ella a la edad para
descubrir las nuevas voces del feminismo
en el mundo vamos a comenzar en chile en
noviembre de 2019 nació en valparaíso
una perfomance contra la violencia
machista un violador en tu camino fue la
forma en la que el colectivo las tesis
comenzó su activismo para atraer la
teoría feminista a la calle y aplicarla
en beneficio de los derechos humanos
nuestro equipo en santiago y en bogotá
contactó a las cuatro fundadoras del
movimiento y el resultado fue el
siguiente
las tesis
sibilla sotomayor dafne valdés paula
cometa y lea cáceres son las cuatro
chilenas que decidieron traer la teoría
feminista a la calle hace mucho tiempo
que teníamos esta esta preocupación alta
urgencia por difundir teoría feminista
en noviembre de 2019 en valparaíso chile
se les escuchó por primera vez
el fenómeno explotó y un año después son
miles y miles de mujeres de todas las
edades de todos los orígenes
gritando en plazas públicas de decenas
de ciudades contra la violencia machista
su mensaje es poderoso
la mujer no se viola no se mata el
sistema patriarcal está en todas partes
si las opresiones de género están en
todas partes operando las distintas
culturas nos pasan todas las fronteras
y la culpa desde el abusador del estado
que no protege del juez que revictimiza
del policía que discrimina una
desprotección que se normaliza a través
de los medios de comunicación y
revictimizan otra una vez más otra vez a
quienes sufren de lesión o de
feminicidio ponen a hacer un perfil de
la víctima ponen fotos desde sus redes
sociales hacen un perfil psicológico de
las víctimas y sin embargo de los
victimarios no sabemos nada
las tesis sellaron el primer aniversario
de esta revolución el 25 de noviembre
día internacional contra la violencia de
género con un canto atronador pero
pacífico en santiago de chile hasta que
en sólo minutos fueron violentamente
dispersadas por los carabineros
ver a abuelas mojadas niñas buscadas fue
realmente violento todo lo contrario de
lo que se esperaba y eso duele
los desencuentros con los pacos o
policías son frontales desde que
decidieron incluir irónicamente partes
del himno de los carabineros en la
performance
[Música]
una crítica que les valió a las tesis
una denuncia penal en junio pasado ya la
responsabilizan por sus acciones
artísticas de que ésta significaría es
una amenaza para los funcionarios de
gardner para estas activistas el
reconocimiento mundial fue un accidente
inesperado pero afortunado así como el
problema global la solución también a
the street global y esperamos vivir para
ver ese cambio
su expectativa era difundir el feminismo
y lo están logrando
en madagascar a de la joven ecofeminista
marie-christine colo exige tolerancia
para las minorías sexuales y lucha
contra la cultura de la violación
france24 se encontró con ella
el taller de este sastre en madagascar
es único todas las personas que trabajan
aquí son trans gays bisexuales o
lesbianas se ganan la vida gracias a
marie christine a color
y realmente el objetivo es poder
devolverle su dignidad de mostrarles a
las personas que no son excluidas no son
parias de talla
la emprendedora y activista de 32 años
nació con el humanismo en su sangre
proveniente de una familia que tuvo la
fortuna de escapar de la pobreza creó su
primera organización benéfica a los 8
años y desde entonces no ha dejado de
combatir la injusticia con el apoyo de
su madre se ha vuelto una de las
principales voces de madagascar en
pronunciarse sobre temas tabú incluida
la violación
todos los sabíamos que un diputado había
violado a una niña joven la familia hizo
todo lo posible por llevarlo a las
cortes pero en su posición el diputado
incluso logró ser reelegido como
vicepresidente de la asamblea nacional
es de donde la sangre nacional en
madagascar una de cada diez mujeres de
más de 15 años ha sido sexualmente
abusada con el objetivo de ayudarlas
marie-christine a creó una plataforma
que provee apoyo legal y psicológico a
las víctimas
marc y cristina nunca ha temido
denunciar los abusos de poder
una de sus primeras grandes causas fue
el cambio climático en el 2016 fundó una
empresa social especializada en
reciclaje
esta tierra la hemos logrado hacer jabón
a partir de aceites de cocina usados por
lo general este aceite se desecha
convirtiéndose en la principal causa de
contaminación del agua en las áreas
urbanas polución de esos hoy nivel no a
todo el mundo le gustan sus esfuerzos
a una lucha muy 7 de junio nuestros
representantes electos nos han llamado
idiotas en basura y otros nombres sólo
porque somos jóvenes tratando de crear
conciencia en la asamblea nacional sobre
los desperdicios de alimentos esas
personas deberían estar avergonzadas
pero en vez de eso insultan a la
juventud que conforman la mayor parte de
este país
houston hop gestión es la más repite la
propiedad es una p mar y christina está
dedicada a seguir denunciando el mal
gobierno la corrupción y otros problemas
que afectan a su país pero más allá de
eso quiere inspirar a los jóvenes a
convertirse por sí mismos en agentes de
cambio
[Música]
desde parís me acompaña a virgin y hertz
se presentadora del programa homónimo de
ella soy en francés actuelles virgin y
en qué medida esta historia es
representativa de las nuevas voces del
feminismo
christina de colores donde existen
buenos días ángel así marie christine
arco lo es el representante de esta
nueva generación de feministas que
luchan en varios frentes simultáneamente
con la misma determinación ese eco
feminista pero también es una feminista
que tiene en cuenta las minorías y esto
es muy importante porque esta nueva
generación de feministas las feministas
interseccional es es decir que toman en
consideración la discriminación que
sufren las mujeres en otros niveles en
términos de raza religión clase social y
discapacidad eventualmente y es una
definición extremadamente amplia del
feminismo que engloba nuevos temas
nuevas luchas como por ejemplo el fin
del silencio en torno a la violencia
sexual pero también la lucha contra el
tabú de la menstruación o el mejor
reparto de la carga mental por lo que
marie cristina es representativa de esta
nueva generación es charles mountain
astuta y diego que se detectó en nube
generación gracias a virginie y desde la
revolución del 25 de enero la capital
egipcia se convirtió en la ciudad más
peligrosa del mundo para las mujeres
o agresión violación lo que tengo en la
calle cada mujer de el cairo ha sufrido
al menos una vez en su vida algún tipo
de violencia en medio de este oscuro
panorama las ciudadanas encuentran
esperanza de la iniciativa soft aja rock
en español vi una cosa liderada por
jalla mostafa un reportaje de france 24
en árabe mientras millones de egipcios
se manifestaban en las calles para tomar
el régimen de hosni mubarak la epidemia
de acoso sexual se propagaba cada vez
más en el país ensombreciendo la
brillante imagen de esta revolución tan
esperada escenas de violaciones sexuales
colectivas en las manifestaciones
conmocionaron tanto a egipto como al
mundo cuando la policía egipcia se quedó
en silencio una mujer pensaba en una
solución para luchar contra este
fenómeno se llama ala mustafa co
fundadora y coordinadora de la
asociación soft ajá roig en aquel mal
benedetta me empecé a trabajar de manera
individual en la sensibilización de las
mujeres para que pudieran defenderse y
enfrentar a sus acosadores
el mutahar gym después del lanzamiento
de esta iniciativa el acoso contra las
mujeres en el cairo empezó a reducirse
de manera considerable y fue posible
para la mustafa al igual que para otras
mujeres dar un paseo por el borde del
nilo sin sentirse amenazadas y sin tener
miedo de ser agredidas
wen es la verdad
efe cuando empezó esta iniciativa y
durante un tiempo pudimos arrojar luz
sobre la gravedad de estas agresiones
contra las mujeres lo que permitió
disminuir de manera relativa su cantidad
luego después de unos cambios
sociopolíticos esta cifra volvió a subir
más que antes como si los hombres
estuvieran vengando de nosotros las
mujeres por reclamar nuestros derechos
al agua de late pájaro startup ha optado
hasta el momento no hay cifras precisas
sobre la cantidad de agresiones contra
las egipcias en la escena pública según
cifras de la onu del 2016 en
colaboración con las autoridades
egipcias más de dos millones y medio de
mujeres son víctimas cada año de
violencias sexuales me dirijo a todos
los padres en egipto por favor sean un
verdadero apoyo para sus hijas
enseñarles a sus hijos a respetar a las
mujeres y no acosar las porque cuando
realmente las respeten no
a molestar ni en la calle ni en nuestros
puertos públicos ni en el trabajo
tampoco van a rebajarlas o maltratar las
y tu mi linda no calles y no te después
de tus derechos incluso aunque esté sola
ante el mundo entero
aunque no crea en la voluntad de las
autoridades para luchar contra el acoso
a la mostaza sigue tratando de cambiar
la mentalidad de los egipcios y de las
egipcias sobre esta epidemia
las alumnas ares la periodista de ella
alejadas la versión en árabe de ella soy
bienvenido a my salud y háblenos de cómo
las sociedades árabes ven el feminismo a
nivel mundial y por qué es importante
que los periodistas hagamos un doble
esfuerzo para romper los estereotipos
sobre las feministas
nada mal esa fue una que sufran que
perdimos tal si desafortunadamente hay
un gran malentendido en cuanto al
término feminismo en el mundo árabe y no
ha mejorado en los últimos años en
especial debido al aumento del
extremismo religioso en estas sociedades
y al caos que se está desarrollando en
ciertas regiones guerras e inseguridad
fueron las consecuencias de la primavera
árabe en muchos países todos estos
factores conducen a más estereotipos
para las feministas sabiamente nanas
habilidad tenemos esterilidad agua
material augur etna and son vistas como
mitad hombres y a veces como prostitutas
que por supuesto es incorrecto
sin embargo desafortunadamente estas
concepciones erróneas se siguen
expandiendo aunque muchas activistas y
feministas tratan de combatirlas cada
día de todas las maneras posibles a
estos militantes todavía les espera un
camino largo además nosotros como
periodistas también deberíamos asumir
nuestra responsabilidad en este asunto
en esto hay donde en la boca se afirmó
que ahora min la dinama su línea fija
está santander
el sistema de castas en la india fue
oficialmente abolido hace décadas sin
embargo sigue existiendo el abuso basado
en creencias tradicionales y los dálits
o intocables son víctimas cuando son
mujeres la discriminación es doble
sarita berma quiere acabar con esta
marca inhumana aquí su retrato por
nuestra cadena en inglés
en india las mujeres de la comunidad
dalit o intocable han sufrido
históricamente en silencio salir a ver
más ha sido testigo de esto
personalmente la mujer del himno puede
hablar delante de su esposo y la familia
no le deja salir de casa si su
responsabilidad son sus dos hijos
entonces esa es la única razón de su
existencia
sarita es activista adalid abogada y
madre de dos hijos está comprometida a
hacer escuchar las voces de mujeres como
ella ya crear una sociedad más justa
para sus hijos fue discriminada por
primera vez en una visita escolar a un
templo hindú lo que sentó las bases de
su trabajo como activista cuando fuimos
el sacerdote me pregunto de qué
comunidades era así que le dije que
significa comunidad qué es lo que quiere
saber él dijo cómo se llama su padre
pero yo no entendía el sistema de castas
entonces me dijo que no fuera más que mi
casta no podía entrar al tema de las
mujeres de la comunidad tienen que
soportar la carga extra de la
discriminación de género
hago agricultura mano de obra limpieza
trabajo de saneamiento público esos son
los tipos de trabajos en los que se
desempeñan nuestras mujeres dalit no
verás a una sola mujer de una casta
superior haciendo sus trabajos
excluidas del discurso principal sobre
los derechos de género las mujeres de
leeds son el blanco fácil de los
crímenes de odio
[Música]
fueron a la puerta con un hacha
golpearon la puerta y la abrieron 10 u
11 personas rompieron la cerradura era
del norte las mujeres a las que los
vecinos de casta superior atacaron en
medio de la noche son las únicas dálits
de la zona fueron intimidadas le dijeron
que abandonaran sus tierras y la policía
se negó a presentar un informe completo
hay muy pocos oficiales de la comunidad
dalit en nuestras estaciones de policía
siempre son de castas superiores y no
quieren que su propia casta se vea mal
delante de naranjilla en el sistema de
castas está arraigado en el tejido mismo
de la sociedad india para sarita a la
lucha por la igualdad tiene un largo
camino por delante y la bienvenida a
anexión una presentadora de fifty one
presents annette después de ver la
historia de la india aún permanece en la
mente de muchos que los países de habla
inglesa son más avanzados en la
conciencia feminista es realmente ese el
caso
y ser bueno si se mira el mundo
anglófono y se lo compara con francia o
el mundo árabe o incluso el mundo
hispanohablante se diría que los
derechos de la mujer tienden a ser más
avanzados sin duda en reino unido- en
australia en nueva zelanda incluso en
canadá en todos estos países ha habido
primeras ministras en algún momento de
la historia reciente y por supuesto en
eeuu a principios de los años 70 vimos
que ese país era el centro de
operaciones de las mujeres y como
resultado fue un concepto que se
discutió no solo en los medios de
comunicación sino también en los hogares
y dio lugar a esa famosa sentencia de la
corte suprema- la sentencia road versus
white que les dio a las mujeres el
derecho a abortar pero después de 47
años las cosas han cambiado sólo tenemos
que mirar a eeuu en los últimos años
para ver que ese país está muy lejos de
alcanzar la paridad política que la
brecha salarial entre los géneros sigue
siendo un gran problema no sólo en eeuu
por supuesto sino también en el reino
unido- en australia y en nueva zelanda y
por supuesto en los últimos años con la
y nación hacia la derecha en particular
en eeuu hemos visto un retroceso en los
derechos reproductivos en todo el país
esto demuestra que no importa en qué
parte del mundo se esté los derechos de
la mujer nunca son algo seguro de hecho
siempre van a estar amenazados
wisekey enterate así llegamos al final
pero son muchas las mujeres que han
pasado por este estudio y que han
aceptado usar nuestros micrófonos para
hablar de lo que debe cambiar para que
las mujeres vivamos en un mundo más
justo algunas de ellas nos enviaron sus
mensajes de aniversario más que
felicitaciones son razones para seguir
trabajando
nos vemos próximamente en ellas hoy
así
verde
hablando del mundo cada perro
en su distrito del memorial es precoz y
fácil el exilio todo religioso
variaciones para las mujeres que estamos
en la política que es una maravilla
conmemorar el séptimo aniversario de un
programa como ellas hoy porque es una
herramienta de transformación de la
sociedad para construir democracias
paritarias igualitarias
aquí no hay límite
puede aliviarse de la actier a mí me ha
sido aplicado la credos femenina de
sudor monitor y tecomán eclipse de nivel
desde con sus discusiones felicitaciones
a ellas hoy por su aniversario no somos
capaces de partida muy difícil fijamente
usamos un poco cumplir que no sabía nada
entró a nivel